[Music]
I think most people are now having have
gotten their coffee and dessert we would
like to get back for the afternoon
session give people a chance to maybe
stretch their legs and get outside of it
when I asked Phil if he would do us the
honor of giving us a talk after this
lunch he said he would think about it
give me his answer in a few days and I
was quite sure he might I think saying
no I came back and he immediately said
I'll I have two options for you and you
know what was going through my mind Phil
was that I've always told Lulu my wife
that if Phil would read from the
telephone book I'd be very happy to come
and hear him because I know that I would
learn something so I really didn't care
which one of the two subjects he was
going to talk about he gave me the two
titles I immediately chose the first one
and I'm so pleased he's going to be
talking about the theory of population
growth this is as he will tell you not
his own
he's been very great pains to tell me
this is the work of Sergio kapitza the
son of the complete so we you all know
and so if people will finish getting the
coffee relaxing then we'll hear about
why it is that maybe oscillations will
not grow exponentially forever and
forever do you like it for a moment
please
well let me delay this by just making a
couple of an observation it's not even
as delay as the as the Chairman I've
been sitting in on all of the talks from
the beginning getting up at an ungodly
hour at 7 o'clock in the morning getting
here by 8:30 and this meeting has done
what we had hoped it would do we started
yesterday morning with as in Martin's
felicitous phrase physics on a human
scale physics that you could get your
hands around and understand physics with
a very different vocabulary physics of
just 40 to 50 years ago and how that has
changed I think those of you who have
been here through that time will agree
with me that this revolution which is
undoubtedly still going on we're just
too close I think or at least I am too
close to see where it's going but this
revolution has taken us from an
understanding that we thought we had and
a set of questions that we were
addressing to realms which have
no obvious connection until you come to
a meeting like this and then you see how
the problems the questions the answers
we're going to hear more of this this
afternoon but this gave me the
opportunity to say something which I
probably will not have time or even want
to say thank you very much I hope you
can hear me I undertook to make this
talk as an old friend of the lab
possibly even a member of the laboratory
of nuclear studies for some time and has
been a delightful occasion I hasten to
point out that what i'm doing here is
reporting the work of someone else it
was a remarkable coincidence Wow Lee
grahdens was on the phone
persuading me with his gentle but
compelling manner which I'm sure you all
know so I could hardly refuse Sergey
kapitsa had entered and was getting
ready to show me a paper he had just
written fresh he's fresh from Moscow so
it's quite a busy morning but what he
showed me was so interesting at the same
time so simple and possibly of great
importance so I thought it was very
worthwhile to learn it which I did and
present it to you I hope you've all got
of this thing shall refer to I'm not
going to give any slides I'm going to
use and discuss in detail the graphs
that are shown here and a few of the
equations which I wrote out describing
the same materials computers but of
course very much abbreviated I should
say a little bit about him possibly you
of course having recognizes his name a
famous name in physics especially in the
physics of the Russians and Soviet Union
but Sergei who was a important
contributor to the study of
instabilities in plasma physics and
therefore knows is not only near physics
quite well and made some most important
contributions in earlier days has for
about 20 years now become a major
television figure on Russian TV across
the entire expense
because he's running for all that time a
weekly program on science an hour a week
and it's very widely known among all
generations everywhere throughout the
Soviet Union in fact at the current time
I'd fret which day of the week it shows
but when it shows it's showing this this
term the season from October November on
til the summer a study of economics and
nearly every week a new economist from
somewhere in the world is produced they
interview him and ask him what he thinks
about this that and the other thing
developed theoretical structure of
economics they have had Friedman and
Galbraith and the usual suspects and I
would not be surprised if some MIT
people have not or will not soon appear
so he was in this country collecting his
tapes so to speak by bearding these
people in their offices to talk to them
in order to put it on TV these had of
course every scientific activity on TV
in all these years very interesting
record
I'm aside he has some time to to do
things and the point which I think I can
most easily make is that it's
appropriate to do this because it comes
out of really I think I could say it
comes out of 1946 just like the nuclear
lab through the then publish public
announcement of the serious
accomplishments of operational
operations research during World War two
in Britain around the physicist Patrick
blackett in the United States around the
physicist Philip Morse of MIT so it's
somewhat reason what we do it yeah this
was a scheme it was really a program
it's still going like many things in
physics it's spun off its own discipline
its own profession its own institutions
but it really began with the physicists
hope that looking at a structuring or a
phenomenon I didn't understand very well
if it had numbers connected to it if you
could somehow connect it with numbers
you'd be able to make some sort of a
semi quantitative stab at doing
something and that regularization would
help him get farther into it
try to help the practitioners whom much
more about the process to see what was
going on and make it work this began in
wartime around the tactical problems of
war how many times you have to approach
a submarine before you can see it on
radar etc that kind of problem left to
the people flying in the field and their
senior officers don't worrying about
them doesn't get very big change
experience is hard to share and hard to
generalize but it was found that if you
got a bunch of physicists the odd
geneticist physiologist and so on to
think about it argue about it in a
quantitative way you could make a theory
which was certainly only a caricature of
the real dynamics of situation these not
laboratory situations you can put them
in the lab modify the parameters look
all around do the kind of wonderful
analysis that the people can do at the
nuclear labs much more like the bad
efforts of the astrophysicists
especially without their powerful
machinery of today so let's you're
looking back in sort of an old astronomy
that's that style of theater Isaac maybe
this is the Kepler of population growth
it certainly is not the detailed
understanding which comes from human
society and it's biological nature but I
think it is important it's certainly
extremely helpful to the physicist
reader to understand what on earth is
going on and some feeling for
quantitative control of it that it is
compellingly true no no one would claim
that not kapitsa and certainly any of
his readers it is an effort at a
phenomenological theory which has a
remarkable support from the degree with
with which only a parameter or two that
makes some sense give sensible values
and fit a very complicated set of data
quite well it looks as though one is on
to something simple not because we
understand the causes but because in the
aggregate some statistical some control
situation makes it work that way pretty
often we were looking not so much at
causes as it consequences and I'll close
with a little more that what I really
wanted was exposed what the theory says
and what the data say I think you'll
find it quite interesting only take me
another 15 minutes
on the first page I put a little
mathematics and I want to make it quite
plain that please do not think of the
population global population n of T as a
solution to an exponential function that
is a straightforward error has nothing
to do with it never was exponential it
was only exponential in the mind of the
Reverend Thomas Malthus who was a very
good theorist of his day but didn't
control much mathematics he probably
knew two or three functions and that was
one of them and it isn't that way at all
I wrote the equation could anybody can
write that one down and it's but it's
really nothing to do with human
population the reason is of course it's
parametric it has a toy in it so if I
allow you to make an arbitrary function
out of tar then I really can't complain
but but if you imagine tar as a constant
then of course you'll be gravely
mistaken
already in the time of good demographic
statistics where errors are not anything
like an order of magnitude more like
1020 percent back to 1800 or so already
the local talk the instantaneous talk
has varied by a factor of 6 or 8 now
that's no proper exponential so you in
time and rather short time compared to
the species a big variation in the
doubling time or the e folding time so
that's really the crudest approximation
of course at any point you can define at
R but that isn't the purpose the purpose
to integrate somehow get some picture of
the whole story and therefore while
extremely simple introducing a
characteristic scale like tah has never
worked and doesn't work now for the
fundamental of the zeroth order
approximation
now the next simpler point which might
be tried and this is known to be very
powerful nowadays we are paying
attention to the nonlinear systems of
all kinds the next simple thing to do is
to look for a scale-free or in invariant
theory which depends on ratios alone and
doesn't have an absolute time or an
absolute number introduced as the zeroth
order Theory that's too hard and it
doesn't work so let's try a scale-free
Theory Delta n over n proportional to
delta T over T
dimensions no no parameters accepted
dimensionless parameter which we might
hope to make hey with making things go
up things go down obviously that's a
very powerful parameter whatever you do
I do this wasn't a very elementary
beginning now at the same time of course
T well why can we introduce a zero of T
let's make the zero explicit and it's
convenient in general to put in a t1 for
some fixed time date and it's also
useful to say we're ahead of that time
day for reason you'll see in the next
statement
so there are county as time from from
from 0 bc say now the original direction
was given to this whole story the
demographers of course is a big subject
matter out there very important very
professional full of people who master
integral equations and do wonderful
things about projecting the population
distribution at one time on to the
population distributions the other time
knowing all the age specific mortality
z' and all the age specific fertility x'
and calculating beautifully what goes on
of course far ahead is pretty hard for
them to do and their tendency has been
not to try to make big projections but
to be guided by strong interpolation
theorems and keep things going more or
less as they are that's about the best
thing can do and that's how the UN works
and does all / get projections and on
the whole they're not too bad but then
of course attract the attention of some
physicists and operations research
people and I gave the two interesting
data which are the key references here I
like to give them both because they
don't differ much but yet there were 15
years apart which is some sign of the
stability of this idea it's only a very
simple naive idea which kapitza takes
off from but I want to put it down as a
foundation the first one was done by
Heights fund first stirred house from
first er in 1960 and published in
science and he noticed from the then
statistics maybe 50 or 60 years of world
population that it fitting very well to
the strictly empirical formula that an
was proportional to a constant of course
a population number divided by t1 minus
t2 the 0.99 power where t1 was 2027 and
point
ix is obviously not the result of the
theory but the result of the parametric
fit done by a careful statistician
because I would never have done that and
Sebastian from Horner 15 years later
looking at the same data a little
further away from Statistics operations
research and demography the fun Horner
is really a radio astronomer decided
well 0.99 invites every physicists call
it one so he did and he only had to
modify the date by two years and this is
you know 50 years in advance of the date
but I want to call your attention to
what the function is and as a constant
divided by t1 minus T and it plainly
diverges at t1 and indeed that was the
point of both of these letters and that
was as far as these people went which I
must say deceived most readers mislead
most readers like me but not readers
like Sergey kapitsa who came around to
it and I suppose other more thoughtful
people because I felt a theory that
leads directly to the burgesses built-in
is hardly worth paying attention to it
might be fun to talk about that but this
is not going to happen and it didn't
occur to me why how to improve by
cutting off the divergence well that's
essentially what Sergey has done he
introduced the way to cut off the
divergence which of course is not real
we don't know much about human
population I would say we know one thing
it's never going to be infinite and
that's therefore I think it's a fair
proposition to change that so how does
he cut it off
he looks around for a parameter that
would be directly translatable into
measurable terms of course so he looks
at the thing and he cuts it off the way
that every physics 802 student would be
able to cut it off by dampening in the
sense of an oscillator or putting
radiative loss or whatever you want to
do with whatever you want to do into any
of these resonant like fermions it's a
resonant for me without the resonance as
soon as you take in dots it becomes
resonant that is the same when I
differentiate I get 1 over T squared and
of course still worst Pole but nobody
expects that Pole we all know what to do
we stick in a toss squared and then the
toss square has a wonderful result
because not only does that give you a
nice form that doesn't diverge
but it directly translates the formula
into a measurable quantity and tars
mainly found by finding n dot max when
the rate of population increase which is
much more measure measurable in the
population you know we're in the modern
world it's all recent data and it's
gathered and summed up and it's probably
not too bad you would have n dot equals
C over toss squared and that's what the
whole thing begins the parameter tar is
clearly going to be rather small length
small time and now I urge you to look
over the page and look at figure three
the top of the two pages in the spread
and there I'm skipping of course a live
numerical fitting a lot of discussion
about interpolation formula about
integrations other things to check it
and make it all proper but I'm just
showing a sir gaze graph of the results
that's a very nice thing to do here you
see the time since 1800 across the
horizontal axis and the population and
units of jayegi heads on the right-hand
axis now if you look up look at the
right-hand part near the right-hand axis
to see the thing in its asymptotic
freedom direction it's easier to read
and there you see there 1 2 3 4 5 6
rapidly rising curves these are simply
different parametric fifths which
kapitsa introduced in order be able to
choose among them the one closest to the
data but to show the general course of
the curve and then on the same part of
the graph he has drawn two dashed lines
these are the extrapolations done by the
rather careful step-by-step
country-by-country age by age epoch by
epoch projections of the UN experts the
demographic experts perhaps the best in
the world and there you are
so you see if you look at it his model 3
somewhere between model 2 and model 3
would split the difference of the UN
completely and he happened to take
Morrow 3 because he did that in advance
of looking up these data he did that a
priori from just making simple steps in
the parameter v to cover the
the parameter space and that's very nice
so you see there it is there's no news
to anybody that we are on a curve which
Rose rose rose went look at curve a
which is now they're all the same up to
the open circle which is the present
time 1990 say and then the five
different models begin to differentiate
themselves at that point followed up and
you'll see what happens now it's nothing
new that there is going to be a plateau
we all expect that it's not even very
much crystal gazing of course tremendous
catastrophes giant nuclear war which I
think has disappeared giant asteroids
which I have not yet appeared barred we
will not have grand catastrophic changes
we kind of control to something like ten
or twenty percent in the future because
we could imagine famines and and great
changes and governments or whatnot but
not very big changes because of course
most of the people who will bear
children in in 2030 or something like
that many of those people are now alive
or 2020 so we have about 30 years head
start and then the rest will not be too
great change
if you don't imagine we're trying to
push it out very far to the very end of
that curve so that's quite reasonable
and it's interesting that his curve
which mind you as a parametric finian
isn't has nothing whatever to do with
the statistics once you accept the
suggestion of from Forrester and fun
Horner that you could indeed fit with a
singularity the local data a hyperbolic
curve why go ahead and try what that
does
and so you see curves a B and C and I
like to call attention three curves in
order a is simply the overall pass which
is all fitted by each of these three
curves
since when you're far enough ahead of
the of the resonant time it does make
any difference whether you dampen the
resonance or not only when you get
across that makes a big difference and
the differences then shown so that's a B
is quite interesting the upper left-hand
corner of that drawing shows the
percentage deviation from the
statistical number the demographers tell
us and
model three it has no significant just
to describe model three but it's
everything to see for comparison how the
real curve looks like when you look at
in some detail instead of broadly
drawing a smooth and over to you and
we're going to see over key curve that's
very very simple that parabola
instead of just drawing that we draw the
detailed curve and we look at the
difference between the digit the the
detail curve and the model curve and you
see it's tolerably good is within a few
percent it looks as though World War one
in World War two show up as actual
modulations of the human population and
what is most interesting is the rise and
decline between 1970 and 2000 this is
something which is not due to this study
it's well known in the empirical data
but it's not called out to people and
it's much better to have this analytic
approach to see how it fits into other
pictures I believe that to be the most
important single result probably were
the most important political points for
the social political future of the world
is governed by that little bump because
that bump is the statement that the
relative growth the percentage growth
per year in population has already
passed its maximum and is empirically
going downward which to a physicist was
some sense of derivatives in an
analytical continuation if not -
somebody wants the hard data what's
actually happening is a very significant
number if the derivative nollie is going
down but if it's already past the
maximum the derivative it's bad luck if
it's not going to do something like that
if there's any reason at all to expected
and all these projections do it both the
empirical ones based on projection of
age groups and this overall grand
parametric one which is so simple but
yet so attractive so there you see in
curve C the maximum of the growth rate
at 2010 just according to the parameters
of kapitza clearly that could be moved
by years either way and then you see the
percentage growth is even more
interesting where the maximum has
already occurred which is true in the
model and true in the reality so if the
curve does not show large deviation
beyond what we expect we have indeed
begun the decline not to decline the
population that would take a long time
because people live a long time not to
be kinder the birthrate that will take a
long time because tiny infant girls grow
up to be mothers and it takes time so
all those things are going to change but
nevertheless the first sign if this is
look for I think is the zero in the
first derivative percentage-wise and
that's been passed an extremely
important result
sorry I'll tell you all those things the
next step now you look at the next page
the last page turn it over the whole
thing look at the last page I want here
to discuss something like it's quite
interesting which kapitza as an expert
in nonlinear phenomenological theories
has done much more than I would have
done I think and it's quite neat of
course first you make it dimensionless
we want to look at the singularities now
the obvious thing glad we already got
rid of by dampening it out and you see
right away that the the dimensionless
function without cutoff is just K over T
and we take T equals zero to be the
future and T going to infinity being the
deep past and so you see n goes to a con
goes to zero sorry n goes to infinity as
T approaches zero that's the bad
singularity we already got rid of but in
the in the zeroth order theory there is
another singularity because of the
extreme symmetry between the variable T
and the variable N and there's all four
also trouble as N equals zero in the
deep past you should examine that as
well it gives strength the understanding
of the curve to see both of those things
happening so of course he proceeds to
cut off both things in the same way and
to fit the parameters and the parameters
fit extremely well with reasonable
values answers your question
tarz about 40 years it's clearly like a
human lifetime because you
at the beginning it tells you what MDOT
must be at the beginning when n is very
small and dot the characteristic rate of
change in dimensions to is something
like 1 over tar the parameter for the
time and that's what you'd expect and
that makes some sense out of the whole
proposition I think now these are two
discontinuities you don't really care
either there's no simple analytical
function for the whole thing but he fits
them together two singularities and it's
pretty reasonable to make it work that
way and all this is described on the
graph you've not yet looked at very
complicated well it's a very rich graph
so I wanted to look at the formula first
now you can interpret this graph very
nicely this second graph the bottom of
the spread kapitza is again is a double
log log log graph logarithm time on the
on the horizontal axis logarithm of
number on the vertical axis and the
three phases of his curve broken by the
two singularities the one in N and the
one in T which are symmetrical are both
present we've already discussed the
single area we're now approaching which
was removed by by a relaxation and there
it is 10 to the 10th population about 10
years before 2010 or something like that
the zero logarithmic zero has been said
of 2010 and then it rises very slowly
asymptotically to maybe 15 billion
that's only the parameter set chosen
here number three number two point five
would be 12 billion the UN minimum is 11
or nine and a half and they you know so
we don't know that we're not claiming
that kind of accuracy but it's a very
reasonable curve now then look at the
curve from ten or a hundred years before
2010 say from the 20th century way back
a million years
it fits tolerably well to that single
straight line on log log paper a
power-law a scale-free dependence as we
said and of course in n dot the rate of
change of population that's a 1 over T
squared but if n is like 1 over T that's
same as in dollars proportional to N
squared for that domain now as Watson
and Crick's said everybody who knows
some my biology knows that the number
two is very important and it doesn't
seem unreasonable that n dot might in
some simple circumstance for a limited
situation in the very complex spectrum
of human society might represent some
important gradation in in that time and
it does seem to fit extremely well over
a very long period notice the curves
they're not the points not tight to the
curve that's quite we don't know them
very well
and there was a change at that time from
species even and certainly from others
to Homo sapiens something might have
happened and I've got surprised that
those dots are missing but essentially
that they fit tolerably well is quite
good that's curve B the free power law
behavior curve C is of course the
asymptotic behavior and curve a is the
behavior from N equals zero which can
only approximate in this de longer than
the curve to n equal one you notice the
symbol put in n equal one and two or
three million years ago when the species
we thought to begin this the Venus
mirror the signal for the first woman is
put there since that must be how the
whole thing began and here for a has no
data at all except he has the point to
which the a curve goes and that point he
got from the French paleontologists were
working in the afar Valley for last few
years and who say that yes they think
that a number like that of the order of
a hundred thousand a million or two
years ago would be very reasonable
number to take I think it's quite
plausible I don't think we can claim
it's known they said he fits it to 69
thousand that's good enough for me and
it helps the parameter description so
nothing too wrong with that so there you
see it and these three regimes there are
the three regimes of human global
population rapid growth when we're only
a few to become a real social being and
a new set of proper species then a
power-law dependent growth with maybe
some Wiggles all the way up to ten or
twenty years ago and then the beginning
of a decline in rate which will become a
real decline until it becomes asymptotic
a hundred years in future that's
the picture of this curve and it is
quite interesting now that's all I
really want to say about the theory you
have the piece of paper you can take it
home and look it over and I think it's
quite interesting I'll say a little bit
about circumstances in my own view of it
just in a hurry and then quit this paper
has been prepared to be delivered to the
International Institute of Applied
systems analysis in Vienna in there in
the forthcoming conference in June of 92
I said that operations research already
had its experts as professions its
societies and its Institute's and this
is one of the best institutes the one in
in vienna i IASA and there it is
they have proceedings and publications
as that high so you can look them up at
your leisure I want to save my own
feeling on reading this why I wanted to
talk about first place of course I make
it very clear as I said the beginning
physicists even expert non-linear
behavior physicists are not very good at
giving the cause of all these things
dynamics is not known this is a
kinematic theory of consequences it's
remarkable that it gives such a
plausible picture and i think that's
what it's good for it's an interpolating
hypothesis suggesting picture to be
tested and used as best you can
very generally nobody would imagine it's
accurate or precise or compelling but
it's very interesting most important
point i've already mentioned i think
that the percentage rate of human
population growth is passed as far as we
know it empirically passed there's no
reason think it'll rise again but might
but we don't think it will then anna's
proportional 1 over t implies when the
situation is far from the singularity
either singularity that n is
proportional to n squared sorry and ozma
portion of n squared and that's exactly
what you want for this twofold nature of
human biology like most other you can
look at another way I suggest a blue
Laplace transform which is also
discussed you can majus to be a very
large some white noise exponential terms
if you like that will also give you
something very similar I don't want to
go into in detail and I remind all the
physicists here probably old enough to
remember at least that fission is
exactly the same sort of thing
is a simple power law the rate of rate
of activity subsequent to uranium
fission follows a pretty close to first
power power law 1.2 shifting to 1.3 or
something that for a long long time
after the Act
what is it composed oh it's composed of
hundreds of species nearly all governed
by beta decay all governed by
exponential decay but summing up many
Exponential's the Laplace transform
naturally leads to something not far
from the power law and if you cancel a
two energy space you'll see behind it's
the energy of beta decay and that's
space and what what various fragments of
nuclei will do but that's goes too far
into the dynamics which were not able to
do in this situation
but I think it's the same kind of thing
it's the summation of many complex
things that have a certain deep
similarity but changing scales all the
time and therefore a scale-free
description is a good first
approximation you must avoid the
infinities and that's what this
particular procedure does like the Higgs
boson it's not guaranteed the only way
to describe the situation therefore I
say that it's analytical it's semi
quantitative it's understandable -
certainly not compelling but it is good
enough to base what I think is
considerable hope for working out of the
giant problems that confront our species
and I'll finally close by saying simply
though it's uncertain it seems to me
that's one of the most important single
quantitative statements the world could
make because while it's a consequence
and not a cause of our actions the
feedback loop of human life is very
strong and therefore energy and food and
transport and war and communications you
name it the problem is there it all is
driven or is related strongly to not
driven by maybe it drives it is both
drives that is driven by the number of
people we must accommodate in a finite
space in a finite atmosphere and
therefore any effort to reduce it to
some kind of plausible reason especially
if this levels simple enough for a
physicist is I think a major
contribution that's why I want to spend
a few minutes in this occasion to tell
you something which is really quite
serious though which comes nevertheless
as a kind of the reduced instruction set
at the end of a very long and
fascinating conference thank you
[Applause]